hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go
subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos as they come out
yeah do it welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage
the show where you find out if your
favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley
hey everybody out there welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage
the show where we sit down with your
favorite comedians and find out if they
go up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host stage foley coming at you on a
beautiful evening here down here at aunt
toody's basement
trying to keep it down she had a long
day she took a couple of pills
she's up there sleeping falling asleep
to jeopardy my co-host
coming at you from right next to me gang
he is the chairman of the board he's got
his name on the lease he's the boss he
writes the checks
he [ __ ] takes the receipts give it up
for the one the only he's in
he's in a lot of debt kevin james ryan
hey what's up everybody
thanks so much for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and
www.patreon.com
are you garbage the money maker folks
check that out
we got a lot of content on there uh for
the first bonus episode we [ __ ]
called our moms and found out who was
trashier so
tune into that couple of real hooies
yeah did she answer
my mom would not have answered that it
was uh i did that i don't do that with
but that's not the relationship i have
with my mom we're like
you know we're like [ __ ] you know
employer employees saying
keep my head down and it's like and as
of recently we've gotten closer but he's
like i called my mom it's all set up and
i waited like 10 minutes before i'm like
hey are you available for a quick phone
call it'll take 10 minutes i'm sorry
i love you my parents are looking for
the spotlight
[ __ ] camera time that's even more
trash yeah yeah they're like doing the
furniture in the back
put the plastic on by the way i love the
board games
we had board games my house every piece
was missing oh yeah yeah monopoly and
had no hotels
yeah couple trailers gang that voice you
here is our incredibly special guest
that is here with us today now tonight
is a family episode gang
where we answer your questions we got to
ask this gentleman
our questions on his previous episode
fantastic episode he is an extended
member of the garbage family we have a
little company tonight
ladies and gentlemen do me a favor this
kid's done it all he's seen it all we
love him
give me a nice big round of applause for
mr mark norman everybody
hey hey good to be back thanks for
coming buddy thanks for having me i was
worried because i mentioned before i
blew my load with all my uh
[ __ ] nanny
uh you know bedwetting and all that but
you guys have prepared questions well
the fans the
so this one of the big things about we
started getting like thousands of
submissions of
[ __ ] these dirtbags all around the
world with their questions that are
fantastic
we can't get to all of them but the
thing about it is if you join the
patreon we automatically answer one of
your questions
yeah you know genius just to drive
business a little bit so these are all
patreon questions these are all patreon
questions
and if you haven't seen mark's episode
you got to go back and watch it and i
just want to be sentimental for a second
and say
your episode was really the first
episode it was a
it was a turning point where really
where where like what
like an intention that i didn't know we
had and a mutual mutual
comic friend of ours said it was
something that the podcast does that i
don't think kevin and i realized
is that it humanizes comedians now i
only knew you a little bit you know i
watched you from afar we loved you
thought you were funny your [ __ ]
i had an idea of who i thought you were
and then when you told your story i was
like you know it was very i texted you
after yeah yeah for like days like dude
that's a [ __ ] script that's [ __ ]
awesome
it was like extremely endearing wow yeah
what did you think i was can i ask
i mean i saw it i figured growing up you
had a little bit of cash
you know what i mean you were [ __ ]
probably the funny kid the cool guy at
school
wow yada yada yeah i thought you were
cruising through i thought it was just
an avenue of green lights man i got a
decent penis
dandruff i had the yellow stains in my
high school uniform
i was a bed winner too that is oh dude
that's tough that's builds character
yeah it's a lot similar to like trying
to like hide a body too like totally
warning it's tough
totally and you got plastic down and
he's a dead hooker it's brutal
when your parents get involved that's
when it gets oh and then they think
something's wrong with you yes
you think there's something wrong with
you my dad's old school he's like
he had all these remedies you know he's
like no more liquids after six people
that was a big one i mean doritos
i was so thirsty my brother's chugging
kool-aid i'm like ah
and i still wet the bed uh it was his
orange piss
just real yellow this kid needs some
water first of all
yeah oh man that was the same the most
embarrassing it was all embarrassing i
did a friend's house on the floor like
ever it's embarrassing it's tough
but my dad even when i'd be like 17 i'd
like
i'd be like i'd call him we'd be like
out drinking or whatever you know and
i'd be like
yo i'm staying at chris's tonight yeah
you're like all right
remember to go to the bathroom and i'm
like ah come on dude
i'm sitting here drinking trying to get
laid and he's like hey don't forget uh
don't don't piss your pants
so you're kind of sweet you did it you
did
he cares he kind of wishes your dad no
he doesn't want him to [ __ ] embarrass
him he'll [ __ ] be pissing at the
mcnulty's house
sleep in the tub wait so you would pee
it as a little kid but then you
as when you're drinking i did that i
don't do it as drinking no
my dad wasn't warning me is drinking he
was warning me as you know you've been
doing this for
15 years knock it off when i drank i it
came back
ah yeah you're kind of numb again you're
in a blackout
you know would you be awake and do it
one of those guys
comes to when pees in the hamper or
whatever yeah now that's weird that's
weird i hated it so much that i
i was so against it but i peed on many
uh one-night stands
dude that's such a tough look yeah you
gotta blame them you're a squirrel
uh one of the dudes from uh uh barstool
uh feidelberg
yeah he was great and he does it like
he's notorious that's his move he's like
dude i just ended up i peed on like
every girl ever
he gets up and spills he spills water
and then leaves it in the bed and goes
oh you you know you must have
you know opened up the bottle of water
yeah smart smart girls are so nice
though like
i'm lucky i'm not a gay guy because i
feel like they'd hit me
but girls are like oh it's okay they're
so understanding because they belong
[ __ ] yeah that's
i think just going through that stuff
yeah you become more of course more
empathetic of course
ladies thank you i've done it when i've
been when i was drunk where i've
been awake but i've been so you know
when you're like you're so [ __ ] up and
you get like the spins
i just pissed and gone to sleep oh yeah
like a
real dirt ball because you're so out of
it you're like yeah just like it feels
that warmth going through your legs
but then it gets that only that warm
lasts for about 90 seconds and it gets
real chilly down there [ __ ] a squirter
once
10 years ago and first of all it was
it was this lady i met she was older she
was a jewish girl from brooklyn
she had eight kids or whatever she's
like i gotta get back to my kids and i
remember i was taking my pants over both
getting naked it was freezing cold out i
lived in a tiny apartment where there
was no
central heat and the heat didn't come on
so we're chilly
and she was like first thing she goes
you better not have a small dick
and i'm like check please i'm undoing my
belt
i'm terrified you know and then past
that point yeah
you bought it how you saw it you're on
the lot i don't know what to tell you
yeah you break the hymen you bought it
and
so we're going at it and she's squirting
like a mane and it was hot it was great
but then you know like you said after
five minutes we're both
sleeping it was like two parentheses on
the edge of the bed because the middle
was freezing and wet
yeah and then she just left damn i just
left the bed like that
that was it left the bed i just slept in
the corner
goodbye better not have a small dick
yeah ouch
man i know i would have just left sorry
it's been fun
yeah by the way i love the the i got a
porn story to tell that's the trash
before so i'm sorry but my friend you
mentioned seeing your
friend's parents [ __ ] in a polaroid
in a poll they weren't [ __ ] it was
it was tasteful posing oh yeah you might
have added some of that too sorry hey
you remember uh you know threesome with
your uh your nephew's parents
so uh me and my friends skateboard we're
all sweaty we run back upstairs
my friend goes i'm gonna jump in the
shower you know we're hanging out in his
room and so you know it's the 90s so
there's a stack of vhs tapes one of them
says skate
so we're like yeah put on escape video
we put it in it goes
you know it's all fuzzy tracking yeah
yeah and then it cuts to
a bathroom closet door is like cutting
off half the frame
and it's his sister naked with the
shower running about to get in the
shower and she's like
feeling herself feeling herself
listening looking at her butt you know
and uh we're just like what the [ __ ]
is going on oh my god holy [ __ ] and then
we're just freaking out it's like
half and excited half curious half
confused and then he comes out you know
he's got the towel like hey what's up he
like tackles the tv
like what the [ __ ] is that he's like you
don't understand she owed me money i had
to bribe her and
i just think he wanted to see a nude
woman it was pre-internet and wow this
is what he had
holy [ __ ] so you hit a [ __ ] camera in
the bathroom
and uh yeah got some footage and we just
happen to find it
christ yeah he's dead now
sister killed him but it's it's weird
being a young boy and this is pre-porn
like online it is it is i had that's
that's [ __ ] nuts i said
i think i've talked about this before my
buddy we were like looking for weed or
something in his parents room and like
they let us heal
he just like let us go through oh wow
and
we all did that though i know totally we
ransacked
everybody's parents bedroom at one point
that's what i've never it was like
everybody was like getting in the mop
everybody had to do it you couldn't hold
that yeah totally
not at my place if i'd had like money
hidden and [ __ ] yeah
yeah um what do you think we were
looking for but we went
we were looking for weed and like i
guess you were also looking for whatever
you were hoping for something weird and
kinky
of course and my buddy not the kid whose
house it was
another friend the third party pulled a
plastic bag out from under the bed it
was like whips and chains
oh a ball gag and [ __ ] and like he like
picked up a dildo i was like look at
this everybody's like put that down
i was like family heirloom embarrassing
dude
yeah whenever you find that stuff you
always the first thing you do is have to
smell it oh yeah you got to figure it
out
yeah that was all to find the panties
you got to smell there's always a smell
thing
little boys [ __ ] teenage boys are
[ __ ] third places man
i've i think i might even i've i think
i've told you this my buddy's dad
owned uh like three independent movie
rental companies
epic video or whatever you know yeah
yeah and then blockbuster came in shut
him down
and he sold all the movies but kept all
the porn
oh yeah so we didn't know and we were
down the basement
uh and it was just boxes like [ __ ]
floor to ceiling
but you have all boxes could you imagine
well we didn't know it was porn
the whole basement like four to six like
thousands tens of thousands of tapes
so we're sitting there and like but it
was kind of a movie it was like goonies
like we were like wrestling and like
fell onto the box and it opened up
we're like dude there's all [ __ ] porn
in here
he's like these are all porn
and we were like so we're like you go
into the speech up there is their time
man
down here down here is our time man now
i'm watching all these pornos and beats
it was gazongas three was the first one
we thought
gazongas
[Laughter]
you jerked off so many times you're like
hey you guys
oh wow brother
and i can i remember the dialogue i'm
telling you right now
those tapes are from my house and one of
them is police academy
the original police that has a crazy
crazy boob scene
at a at a bonsai i don't remember that
in the middle of dude
was that 80s or 90s it was 80s dude 80s
boobs oh my god the chicks would just
come out
oh yeah with chicks with the big banana
boobs and they had the tan lines from
the bikinis
oh boy pull it up
the 80's because porn is so easy to get
now so it's in your yeah
your phone i got to get off of i got to
get away from it too much you got to get
off
but yeah it's funny because when you see
those it's almost like when you have a
song on your ipod or whatever it's fine
but when you see
when it comes on the radio in your car
it's exciting and it's the same with old
boobs you know when they come on
spontaneously like oh [ __ ] oh boo but
you would never look up
boobs sure you never go boobs yeah but
when you see one when you see one kind
of in the wild it's a little more
unexpected you know what i mean exactly
yeah and kids today they'll never have
that and it's funny you related that to
the song because i used to be like that
like a
like a song would play and i'd be like
oh my god i love that song wouldn't know
the name wouldn't know who it was
like spend months trying to figure out
what it was trying to find then it would
come on again you'd be like oh my god
this is it
totally and now it's just like you know
[ __ ] pandora whatever you want to
hear it's [ __ ] crazy you can type in
like three lyrics and you'll find it
yeah
good stuff good old days the good old
days gang do you think people did this
back because
technology's obviously changing at a
rapid rate but you think back when it
was changing
slower they were older guys when like
the phonograph came out we're like oh
remember we had to
learn to play the band sure you guys can
do this
these guys in their fancy fm radio yeah
we had to paint
guys now you can just take a flash
photography yeah when i was a kid i'm
sure
because it's human nature i think you
think about that in the 80s like even
like the little access we had to like
pornography and stuff like that
i still would like think back to like my
dad's generation and be like man that
must have [ __ ] sucked
yeah you watch a stag film you had to
get
yeah yeah that must and it was probably
terrible of course you know what i mean
yeah they're not taking care of
themselves
no no it's also weird to think about i'm
sorry we're we're not
we're ripping this is a show baby okay
but think about like cars came in
obviously so it was all horses horse and
buggy wagons
we're going way back you think cars came
into everybody's like cars are dangerous
they were hitting everybody because they
were still new and nobody knew how to
drive them
and there was dead horses everywhere
because the horses
like one of the jobs like a horse will
just die you know you have a car forever
you see a old car in a field and it's
got [ __ ]
there were dead horses all over new york
before the car so that was just a thing
yeah there's a dead horse like an
abandoned horse it was like an abandoned
car yeah
but it's crazy the thing capture off of
it imagine just walking around like ah
there's a dead horse on broadway there's
a lead horse on wall street
i think about that someone in my
neighborhood i live all the way uptown
in the heights uh
they have a horse no but they somebody
started posting pictures from like
1922 or oh yeah or maybe even earlier
on like just like hey neighbor check
this out this is this intersection
and it's [ __ ] wild to see it really
yeah man it's like the suburbs
i know it was like instead of being like
a house of a building every two
two inches it's like and then you think
every 200 yards everybody in this photo
was dead
they were all had a boner they were all
heading securities they all had you know
diarrhea at some point and they're all
gone yeah there's a famous quote i can't
remember who it is but
they said something like you know new
york city is about your experience
now what it's about is the millions that
came before you
yeah and i mean like exactly like a lot
like just even in this [ __ ] building
yeah in whatever way before you know
just you know hundreds you know 100
years of just lives is going and going
and going
yeah sewing factory next door
nice little sweatshop
[Laughter]
all right well let's get into some
[ __ ] patreon questions here we got a
little company tonight as we said mr
mark norman sitting with us
if you haven't seen this episode it's
out there right now you can find it
anywhere you listen to podcasts or on
our youtube page
go and check it out also love them even
more check out his podcast tuesdays with
stories of course buddy it's a hot one
you guys gotta do
hot you guys hop up hot pot there's
something too like at a point
when you guys were both opening for
louis
it was like it was a wild [ __ ] you
guys are only private jets all the you
guys had this
such a unique oh yeah i remember us now
let's talk about it after we listen
we're down in the village [ __ ]
yeah well speaking of going back we all
did that we were parking
i was barking for uh the village lantern
yeah that's where we
are okay yeah wow look at that it's
cycles baby
yeah we made it to 38th street who would
have thought
we're on the road you'll be on a it's
fun having garbage
on a jet yeah you know yeah because you
have that run opening up for schumer
private jet sushi i mean i bought an
apartment off of the money
madison square garden carnegie hall you
know and people people give her [ __ ]
like oh schumer but i'm like
she stayed loyal she let all these she
let me open for sam open
every list open yeah everybody was
opening and she paid very well and we
had a [ __ ]
blast just the ladies you hooked up with
that was when bumble was new
and that was uh that was uh it's like a
wild west
oh yeah good time that's like the same
thing people try to give pete davidson
[ __ ] but dude the guy he
[ __ ] brings all and they're all
deserving comics they're all fantastic
but it's all his crew on the road
everybody's in the movies he helps
people with projects
that's what it's all about it's [ __ ]
awesome yes exactly
good [ __ ] you want to open for me this
weekend
atlantic city comedy club what's the
private jet situation that's right me
and kippy december 3rd december
atlantic city theater at the clearidge
it's a good room i just did it yeah it's
good stuff
good time shout out to new york comedy
club i got heckled for an hour
seriously an hour straight and two black
ladies walked and said get your clan
hood if you ever come to l.a i'm going
to beat the [ __ ] out all right philly
i'll beat the [ __ ] out of you oh they
mean [ __ ] around with philly
they mean it but i guess i am racist
because uh the two
the black people in the table in front
of them loved it and i was like they
like it yeah like all black people are
the same yeah
like what are you talking about they
like it they're black
looking for validation yeah yeah and the
black guy was like
you're on your own that's funny
good [ __ ] what do we got kip all right
these are all from patreon as i think i
think i mentioned
if when you sign up for patreon we will
read one of your questions we're gonna
we read everybody's questions but
someone we just can't get to
um so this is it this is the first one
and this is one
that i have uh history with this is from
dan have you ever had a life-size cut
out display of like a movie theater
in your home i had a movie i had a
life-size
superman from where six foot you know it
was like i stole it from the amc
yeah christopher reeves and he was like
going like this flying pretty awesome i
had to cut out with the little
stand behind him was in my room it
looked pretty cool the only problem is
you come home after a few
uh but i had ices and you're like oh
and then of course you also get the fun
part where he gets into the wheelchair
accident so you get to bend the poster
you know you roll it down yeah you put
them on like an office chair and
wheel them across the living room those
things usually had a dick drawn on it
yeah or a
hole where the penis would go we were we
were older and we stole
uh from like a south philly sports bar
and grill or whatever we were in like
our 20s and we stole a
thing of darren dalton from out these
like it cut out he was like advertising
something and everything
we cut a hole in the dick yeah like my
buddy we could always like be
pre-game and he was just behind it with
a stick hanging out classic move
anytime you pull out a dick it's funny
that would be assault now
yeah yeah it's funny yeah we were we
were in posters
we did po i remember going to that
trashy we are we would go to like
not it must have been poster conventions
or something we did that
we did yeah a poster convention what
were they it would be it like
shops i didn't go to a convention this
was like not a loser it must have been
like a music convention or something
like that but i remember buying like
rolling stone
posters like the huge they did like
memorabilia
yeah before the internet it was like
we'll all get together and everybody
will come out to buy these t-shirts that
was ebay
cds and stuff exactly yeah yeah that was
really trashy coming up
yeah i got a i got a blues brothers
poster
[ __ ] and rips and [ __ ] in it oh this
is what i learned in college and it's
just a bunch of shots
oh like sex positions or whatever oh
man i'm not as thick as you drunk i am
bob marley and looking back i was like
this will never not be cool
like 24 like oh such a [ __ ] the john
belushi
uh the one where he's wearing the cop
college yeah
younger than you even when i went to
college everybody [ __ ] had it yeah
one thing i'm glad i never got into
is the black light [ __ ] ah i was a big
guy
on the ceiling
room 204 there this [ __ ] got real trippy
in that [ __ ] joint
was that a jizz stain billy it was it
was uh it was detergent that's what we'd
use to write detergent
detergents would show up in a black
light yeah but your teeth always look
[ __ ] yeah
every stain every piece of dog hair got
[ __ ]
illuminated and you lit i hated it there
was this one dorm that had like black
lights
yeah come over i'm like i'm not getting
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] awesome they call your
[ __ ]
i remember kids that had like a fake
tooth they'd have like an implant
and they would smile like everything
would glow but that one yeah what is
that lead what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is that made of dude by the way
nothing trasher than the nicorette
that's waiting for you
you got the [ __ ] come waiting you
can't wait he's down
here too he's such a piece of garbage
that's hilarious
doc said i gotta quit smoking yep
until he turned to candy that's great
whatever happened to the patch
is that gone i feel like that's too that
was big for him that was big nicoderm
yeah yeah thank you now it's all chantix
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you up though yeah
[ __ ] up that's the pill you take
and it really is the right thing
yeah i only know i only know it from who
does it kyle donaghy kyle donaghy
oh my god it's [ __ ] champion they're
so funny
i tried everything to quit smoking
hookers nothing worked
he's still smoking he's one of those
guys where you're like you know they
always say oh the cream rises the funny
people will make it don't worry and
you're like what about kyle dunnigan
i'm so great and then brogan shouted him
out and now he's yeah
unbelievable his things with his mom mom
what are you doing
yeah same kardashians he kills it yeah
totally
bruce jenner or caitlyn is it uh
oh boy caitlyn jenner sorry
um what's next all right this is from
jeff have you ever ordered off the kid's
menu as an adult
oh yeah yeah baked chicken fries if it's
dude if the platter's not on the
appetizer i got i gotta get gotta go
kids uh if i was waiting tables i would
make you feel like a piece of [ __ ] for
doing hahaha
you wanna dry up a vagina
yeah do you still want the juice box
yeah [ __ ] it i'll take it it could be a
crayon at it
coming out of your tip some boston guy i
wish i knew who it was but he says great
joke about how he's so
cheap he's like you ever go to the
restaurant you're like you look at the
man you're like oh i'll have the
additional topping because it's the only
thing on there it's like 4.99 that's
pretty good
i wish i knew what that was somebody
right oh yeah put that in the car that's
a [ __ ] horse
slices and some onions yeah i love the
coleslaw
i will say this when i when i go to
mcdonald's with my niece and nephew that
you know they get happy meals obviously
i am real envious of those things
oh there was something about popping one
of those things open in the 80s totally
so
colorful and the total toy in the bag
burger smell
coming out of that thing they did it
they really [ __ ] whoever's
was behind that new psychology to get
the [ __ ] hooks and kids
totally totally and i feel so bad for my
parents because we'd go to remember i
don't know this is this is deep
deep dive [ __ ] but nickelodeon would
have like things like
go to mcdonald's and say the password or
give you an extra cookie or whatever
yeah
and so my dad's like hungover you know
he's got a five o'clock he's gotta say
slimers yeah he's got a wife
and he's like what what he's like my
kids say
nick jr
my dad was a big milk guy
that's at mcdonald's killer yeah that's
lunatic a big one on the show i don't
know if we did it with you
we did your episode a while ago did you
drink milk with dinner growing up
yeah that's lunatic [ __ ] yeah it's too
heavy my parents
they bought powdered milk yeah we did
talk about this yeah so we didn't have
real milk
he she didn't grow up on rikers at sound
yeah didn't you have powdered eggs too
weren't you a powdered egg family no
we'd have a powdered egg it was the
powder
i remember the powdered milk and that's
when i was like damn i was i felt bad
for you yeah it sucked
i just didn't [ __ ] with milk dude no
[ __ ] we had ice cold vitamin d
thank you daddy that's the dream oh the
best
i love it man that's great great
question great [ __ ] question yes i
feel like
i feel like norman might uh fall into
this one because he was a bit of a
rabble rouser as a kid
yeah this was from connor true have you
ever written on the wall of a bathroom
or a porta potty
what are you kidding come on never liked
that [ __ ] i don't think i ever did
i see it now
all that is you know one guy would say
something in the comment guy like this
with a dick i mean it was gold it was
always just your mom's a [ __ ] this that
somebody's number
for a good time that's a classic bit
though i mean i was at a dive bar in new
orleans i don't know
you know i just spent my whole 20s at
dive bars and i was you know half in the
bag
pissing and one guy said the hottest
girl you've ever seen
some guy's tired of [ __ ] her number
[Music]
like blew my mind
yeah totally and i remember be like
because you know we weren't getting laid
and no hot chick was ever going to talk
to me but
reading that you always you know you
walk out you feel pretty good that's
awesome yeah show me show me a hacker
i'll show you a guy who's tired that
wasn't her that was that's
good there's also an old joke that like
guys only sleep with girls so they could
tell somebody
and there was there's an old joke about
a guy who was stuck on a desert island
with
brook shields it was an 80s joke and
after like a year being there together
you know i've done everything under the
sun she's like is there anything you
want me to do
and he's like yeah well you put this
face fake mustache on
so she puts it on and he walks up and
goes hey you're not gonna believe where
i'm [ __ ]
now wow see that's that's layered that's
deeper
i [ __ ] love street jokes i do too
they're brilliant and we know
don't know who we're it's it's such a
shame because i love a good joke
some uncle somewhere some perfect joke
somebody doesn't get credible
even the little stuff like when it's the
first guy to go is that clear crystal
yeah no credit or a guy like a good that
that's what she said
nothing wrong with that that one guy
said that he got 18 high fives and no
credit
yeah i used to think about that [ __ ]
when i was a kid uh because in the 80s
there was a rumor that my one friend's
older brother's cousin
whoa came up with the the saying
it's all good yeah no i swear to god
obviously
get the [ __ ] out of here dude he's been
selling me this live for like
a decade shout out to andre klein they
were the cool they were the coolest kids
in the neighborhood man and his cousin
was from like georgia and he would come
up in the summer
they'd have the wave caps on they always
had like the newest rap and all that
stuff they were [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
he's a kid polish he used to always say
it's all good and then
then like years later it started to take
off but like who comes up with those
sayings even even like calling uh you
know diamonds water or ice or whatever
like yeah
you mean yeah yeah yeah yeah it's crazy
and i think bling bling was little wayne
actually yeah i think that was
a new orleans and i remember yeah it was
and i think uh birdman was like looking
back i should have [ __ ] copywritten
it and i would have been a billionaire
i remember hearing like obama said it
once or something so it just it's crazy
how it starts in this ghetto or whatever
it gets into some rap and then
five years later old corny guys are
saying yeah it becomes part of the
vernacular the zeitgeist zeitgeist i was
just watching the uh the seinfeld where
they go
to uh joe mayo's party the new
housewarming
party i think it was i think that's the
party he's the one that gives everybody
the job right
yeah yeah yeah and jerry goes yeah
i got jiggy with it and it's so
cringe-worthy i'm like ah you're just
this
old white guy trying to act cool but was
he trying i think it was ironic
i think so too but still i think the
fact that it even made it in
it was like a year after the song came
out yeah yeah i got
jiggy with it yeah upper middle class
cheesy white people but somebody to come
up with that's lit
and that's ratchet i mean all that [ __ ]
somebody thought of that one
yeah one person damn that's why i try to
make up my own like seinfeld they had
you know yadda yadda nothing
wrong with that they came up with their
own man i'm a mama yeah
dude [ __ ] clothes talker low talker
all of them all every gifter it's like
jewish ebonics
estelle's got the jimmy like yeah dude
there's so many
shout out to seinfeld check it out on
hulu yeah if you haven't already yeah
they caught an episode they could use
they could use the boost
ah my favorite street joke i think we've
talked about this before is uh
the pedophiles walking a seven-year-old
get into the world
and the kids crying he goes what are you
crying for i gotta come out of here by
myself
that's just [ __ ] great i think a lot
of that [ __ ] came out of the military i
think a lot of guys
because everybody's in the in the
service back then you just have to be
with eight guys in the woods you know
just [ __ ] yucking it up yucking it up
no book no
nothing just talking man that's a good
street joke
yeah good street journal podcast
oh that's a great call oh cut that out
don't let anybody hear that
copyright are you garbage 20. that'll be
on the patreon um
okay this is from joshua marbury has a
member in your family ever used plastic
bags or garbage bags as luggage if yes
have you ever taken it on an airplane oh
yeah i did that last weekend oh my god
dude
i have money norman i can one-up that i
didn't even use a garbage bag because i
couldn't find any so i used a pillowcase
what yeah because i had a bunch of merch
and i was like i'm not bringing a whole
suitcase because i can leave the
pillowcase
in milwaukee right now if you sell the
merch yeah or fold it and put it in your
luggage
it was too full i had more merch in the
luggage oh my
god this guy was a mover and shaker
[ __ ] fire sale over here
he's like crazy oh yeah right right so
i'm at you know newark with a [ __ ]
luggage thing in my hand i threw that in
the uh overhead and you had a pillowcase
you got like you got the roller bag the
drag bag yep and then
a pillowcase full of [ __ ] parts they
let you have a personal
the personal like school bag and an
overhead compartment bag
what's more personal than a pillowcase
but were you flying coach or first class
i was business
yeah they must have been looking at you
oh you look like a trick-or-treater
they were going this is a bump up this
guy got bumped up
yeah the scooby-doo didn't help
i'm a big fan of the bump up you know
that oh i'll wait around for [ __ ] six
hundred dollars worth of amex gift cards
i'll say
that the buck the wedding the bump up is
better than the the buying first class
like
getting the bump huge huge uh i've only
had a feeling first class once and
somebody bought me the ticket
it was [ __ ] nice they got us dude
they get you so drunk we were going out
for a bachelor party to miami
and they knew we were on a bachelor
party they were just bringing over like
four or five of the vodka bottles like
the little guys
yeah for each of us i mean it was like a
[ __ ] 45-minute flight and we drank
them out oh no that's too quick you
wanted to you want it you want the
[ __ ] trans continental totally
totally i flew from
one of the few first class from uh cross
country was uh new york to la
jet blue mint is that the sleeper yes
the jet blue jet blue really stepped
their game up it's unreal you got the
sleeper all the best movies
uh you know they they give you a menu
you can pick what you want and
everything's like and they tell you
about the food this is actually john
wolfgang puck's
private resume you're like oh jesus yeah
that's awesome you start dozing off but
you got to stay up because you want
to get all you want the perks yeah
taking some coffee over here yeah
because yeah you came from humble
beginnings what was that like flying
private for the first time oh
it was insane
that's gotta be getting on the plane on
the tarmac yeah
that's gotta be a good [ __ ] feeling
well you know you're a piece of [ __ ]
when they they bring it to teterboro
which is where the jets go and
uh the just the hub like what do you
call it the terminal
the terminal yeah the terminal it's got
free cookies free muffins
free coffee you're putting them in your
bag i'm stealing all that [ __ ] and
they're like
you're already on the jet you psycho
there's food on the jet i was like oh i
didn't know there was food on the jet
but it's just
it's weird to go from gym you have
jailhouse mentality right
you're like here's resources yes
nobody was eating them
i think we've talked about i think we
talked about it on your episode but the
fact there's stories of you
at uh well i'm sorry what's the name of
your show in the upper west on the upper
east side
like irish exit hot soup yeah yeah wow
yeah i mean comedy is dead but you would
go up to uh
[Laughter]
you would go but you would act like a
busboy to take people's
plates see that's every time that's the
guy i thought you always wanted to go
to go eat the food off the bus off said
bus
plate and then go up on stage as a comic
but how confident is it i'm eating the
discards of strangers
but just being able to walk up to
somebody you're done with that and take
it away it's never failed it's [ __ ]
foolproof
oh my god that's insane i imagine the
irish sex would probably put out a
pretty decent chicken wing too
solid solid wing and i like the flats
they had a good flat
that's funny man um all right
all right this is from ttak uh have you
ever washed an item of clothing in the
sink because you're too lazy to do a
full load of laundry for the next day
oh yeah of course pair of undies or
socks or something
oh yeah yeah i mean i could use a
washing machine when i was four with the
bed wedding
yeah yeah i knew my way around the
[ __ ] permanent press
totally yeah totally yeah but i've
definitely done the sink with the skid
marks
you know that's that's happened a few
times uh you got a hot date but you
can't find any fresh undies so you got
to find the one on the floor you get the
skid marks out you throw those puppies
on
yeah that was back when you just had
white underwear i didn't know what i was
thinking
oh yeah yeah yeah long time ago
yeah not a good look no matter how in
shape your dad was or whatever
you catch him in a pair of tighty
weights a couple of yellow stains on the
front balls are hanging down real low
completely my dad was robe no undies guy
too
hey you said that oh did i say that yeah
but that's the same thing yeah that's
still one of those so you caught a peek
every once in a while oh yeah he was
huge
he got a unit on him huge the whole
thing was you like he would turn and it
would like it
was just a delay you know
huge balls hairy brown balls
my dad's sack was enormous if there was
jeans it was like
it was just like it's like a lava lamp
you know it's so
slow we got one shut up hey that thing's
[ __ ] broken yeah we don't plug it in
those guys
you got to keep the electric low you
know those guys were more men than what
oh yeah oh yeah for all the reasons that
we've talked about just on this bike
sure yeah military what they had access
to they say
i don't know this is like a real
scientific fact but kids are [ __ ] way
less than
people used to [ __ ] i guess because you
got more things to do you got phones yes
you got computer you got netflix so
people are [ __ ] his entertainment in
a way
so if you have more things to do you're
gonna [ __ ] less and plus like sexual
assault
and me too and whatever the [ __ ] so kids
are [ __ ] less
but also you gotta think like maybe
women are turned on less
because we've gotten way softer true
like
yeah we're i guess as a you know we're
less masculine for sure
yeah as compared to previously but we
don't know i think men are confused
especially
i mean i'm i'm almost 40. but i think
younger guys are just like do i be
take chargey or is that mansplainy or do
i be aggressive or is that aggressive or
what you know like
i don't think guys you know back then
you're like all right burt reynolds i'll
be that guy that's
that's my archetype yeah
what are my hairy styles you know like
what do you look to now as a guy
yeah it's true it's true it's tough it's
tough
right call in if you're 25 i don't know
what you go with but
i guess it was because i was a kid but
like those guys all had like dad vibes
to me and i mean like even though i got
to watch the a team they were all like
my dad's eight yeah they were all tough
as [ __ ] and they were still
cool there was some it was like in the
80s in like early 90s it was like
it was cool to be uncool does that make
sense
i don't know what you mean but i don't
know like they were cool they weren't
yeah i feel like it's more now they were
like shooting [ __ ] tommy guns and
blowing up no but i mean like you know
like uh like they weren't wearing like
the best sneakers they'd be like
like you know if you look at eddie
murphy in uh in beverly hills cop
he has a shitty pair of sneakers on a
real pair of shitty jeans and like a
shitty detroit jacket but he looked
[ __ ] cool
they did look cool yeah but now they
would be like jordans they're
like 300 jeans think i think that was
cool at the time he had like a pair of
like nike running shoes on that was cool
and i think he just progressed
so much to the point where like men's
athletic shoes weren't a fashion
statement yeah
they were just like that's what you wore
that's what you wore
it's like now the fashion has played
such a big role also he's supposed to be
a detroit
beat cop yeah so i don't think we can go
too hard into the fashion world right
because it would throw off his character
yeah it makes sense all right i'll go
[ __ ] myself there you go big man
all right this one's from uh ben zimmer
this is i've
definitely [ __ ] have done this what's
the worst what's the trashiest item
you've used as a window blind for
example
i family taped a pillowcase over the
window and waited weeks to buy a proper
one
wow that's a big pillowcase jesus that's
not
that's not a carry-on well my brother
was goth so he had just a full blackout
yeah sheets or were they curtain like
proper curtains i think
they were like blankets like black
blankets uh which was just
terrifying you know kids were something
else yeah he had the makeup
and the fingernails and the fishnet
whatever does he still rock that [ __ ] no
no he you know he's 42 now but uh back
in the day he was
full in goth he had he was kind of
troubled he was one of those kids he had
like
the butt cut and one half was black one
half was white oh
yeah he was all in that was big we grew
up in a black neighborhood we didn't
know where to go we didn't know what we
were and so
he went goth and i went full skateboard
grunge thing yeah
and uh that was back when like now you
talk about progress
i see all these black kids skateboarding
yeah and they used to chase us
for skateboarding they'd be like get a
basketball you weirdo you know
but uh now it's it's a little more fluid
yeah
everybody's mixing in i love it it's
great but yeah curtains i mean towels up
there
blankets for like a while yeah yeah yeah
my parents at their their side door like
lets him like a serious
draft so still every winter there's a
saint joe's like
almost like a military blanket that they
have like a special bar
like almost like a it's like a
clothesline but it'll go like that and
it'll go like that
yeah and at night they'll [ __ ] put
the blanket over it and then put it on
the door so the giraffe doesn't come in
oh you know also
that's trash also trashy was the uh
i don't know what you call those the
plasticky kind of nylony
venetian blinds the venetian but the
plastic ones where every now then the
side one will be like
oh yeah they were a little bent over and
that was
all [ __ ] up yeah
yeah yeah yeah clink too much
never stuck you know you're like all
right then i pull out oh hold
on hold on yeah yeah yeah i feel like a
sailor when i'm doing it
[Laughter]
that's a great question i remember my
buddy when it comes to car windows
we drove around for four years of high
school with my one buddies [ __ ]
datsun
where his his driver's side door just
had a plastic bag
like like a trash bag where he couldn't
see
out of the left side of his car and we
would just we just [ __ ] back and
forth to the shore
[ __ ] smoking weed just [ __ ] air
there's no coming back from that no one
goes plastic bag
and then fixes it no it's just that's a
give you're giving up you got a 48 hour
yeah
if you don't do it in the yeah you don't
do it by the weekend it's a wrap
how about this one you remember that
weird uh cardboard
pull out thing that unfolded for the sun
for the sun
people had a pair of sunglasses on the
front
[Music]
i never got the club i feel like i could
steal this car and get away with it
yeah exactly but uh the the the the
[ __ ] sunglass thing
i got it because one time i left a
cassette tape and that [ __ ] warped
pretty quick on the dash so i get a hot
car in the summer in the evening
those seats will just [ __ ] burn the
bottom of your legs so
brutal and nowadays people lease cars
and [ __ ] like that that wasn't that
prevalent back then so like i remember
if something happened to one of our cars
like if a back window
wouldn't go up or something like that or
like if it was stuck
it was just left it wasn't getting fixed
that was just
a thing you had to overcome your process
to get into the car
or if the door didn't open from the
outside or if the remote didn't work
dude you're not opening from the outside
you got to like [ __ ] reach back and
unlock it
pop it open or the window would break
and you'd have to open the door and get
two hands on it and like [ __ ]
jam it up and then you know my dad's
like don't do it don't put it down
dude they're all every time you get in
and start the car they warn you don't
touch that [ __ ] woman
we had a garage door like that if you
touch the [ __ ] garage door thing he
was gonna lose it because
it was a 50 50 shot it was gonna get
stuck halfway through totally
uh speaking of cars this is a good one
uh this is from doug hanson
do you or any close member have a loved
one's birth date and death day
decal on your car oh like you know
[ __ ]
aunt hoodie from
[Laughter]
that was like a latino thing or it's
definitely yeah it's definitely more
prominent latino uh
population i feel i never had i had a
body that had it
uh on his like car in high school
someone oh yeah and he had it yeah
the white guy version of that is that
weird cross on the side of the freeway
you know like putting in the dirt
somebody got popped yeah exactly it says
like dog on it yeah it's got a couple of
wreaths on it you know
or have you ever seen a all-white
bicycle yes
yes fallen soldier
somebody went out for milk and then take
it back
[Laughter]
i don't know if i'd want any of that i
definitely wouldn't want my face on a
t-shirt
no [ __ ] that yeah i don't want a death
picture yeah
good point you know because you don't
get to pick the picture no
how do you want your funeral because
he's he will you wear very anti-beef and
beer
yeah i don't like i don't want a bamboo
you know a beef and beer it's like a
very northeast thing like a beef and
beer would be like
awake you know but it's like a
fundraiser
it's 50 bucks for trash all you can eat
and drink
to raise money for his family the beef
would be like a roast beef sandwich
oh i like that it's just kind of like
you like the sandwich yeah yeah
that's a little horseradish on there
kaiser roll yeah who doesn't
right meanwhile there's a picture of you
up on a [ __ ] screen like
i would love to go out to irish wake
style like at an irish pub on the pool
table with like
oh yeah that would be so cool yes
[ __ ]
everybody i'd be in your bodies or
something yeah i'm just watching
propped me up everybody's hanging out
boozing now the thing i was always
staunch on is i don't want an open
camera he's upset i left
i don't want an open casket i want
people looking at me unless you do go
old school put the quarters on my eyes
so i got a little cash for the fairy man
you know what i mean
coming up short hey you can't take it
with you
ah that's too good ah this is what we we
kind of touched on uh this is from jess
la domirera or brian just da la my
herrera
i don't know shout out to dominic billy
comic well a lot of the history hyenas
make jokes about their names and then
they i think they then
yeah i love it um will you turn your
underwear inside out to re-wear them
when laundry's not done
sure i do i do that normally i mean you
get two
wears out of the undies you do that
every day like on monday you'll put them
on and then tuesday you flip them
oh man that's pretty wild that's pretty
wild
i'll do that with a t-shirt i'll wear
the t-shirt inside i'll wear a t-shirt
but you got the tag going it doesn't
matter
what i mean we're not really yeah we're
not going
to buy a big donut we're going for
whatever covers them at this point
yeah i don't care if he wears it for a
month that's how i pick i picture what
covers my belly and i gotta do the the
fat guy stretch on this shirt which
it used to be uh uh [ __ ] advertise we
used to advertise with them
sheath dude you can wear those things
for a month you got them on
yeah yeah yeah larger set yeah they're
inside out actually
at the moment dude oh yeah i did those
like friday saturday sunday monday
totally yeah do you do the ball in and
the whole go in both pouches
in the sheaths i've never tried it i
just put them on and walk away
yeah i go in the pouches the thing is
you can separate the dick in the balls
yeah i don't i don't got that kind of
poise down there
my guys are watching each other's back
like two [ __ ] cherries in vietnam
[ __ ]
back-to-back [ __ ] nobody's getting
separated right right
not walking around the haunted house by
ourselves stay together fellas
keep it oh that's right that's a great
question though
oh man i heard [ __ ] mike cannon say
this weekend he's like it's so cold
outside he goes
about my it looks like i have three
testicles
that's so funny i went to her for a
physical and i had a woman doctor and it
was chilly and i was worried she was
going to chill
not that she'd be looking but it would
still be like hey i'm not a real man
i i had a similar thing i was running
because i was late so i wanted to be on
time and you know when you run or where
you exercise your dick goes inward
yeah yeah it's like a survival thing
mine hangs out on the inside most days
anyways oh yeah but she's
survival i got a physical and it was it
was like an acorn it was brutal
female doctor yeah attractive yeah oh
man i know i was like 19 too and you
know his prime like oh
maybe it's like a porn yeah yeah she
felt that acorn
brutal i buried it for the winter candy
a lollipop told you to beat it
yeah i remember my first one you have to
get i think when you're like 13 or 14
like junior high or whatever
and i went into the bathroom and like
chubbed up like not tripped
up yeah i [ __ ] for a female doctor or
a guy doctor i didn't know who i was
getting she wanted to show off whoever
whoever was i want the flex on word of
mouth advertising
ruled in the 90s no but it was just like
well it could have either been a guy or
a girl it's kind of whoever like
grabs your fat like would next up on
docket really yeah you would go to like
a practice like a barber
please i have this for the russian guy
dr rogers
no it was like you made an appointment
at dr barbara's office and then there
was like three people
that you could have got oh i was just
kind of whoever was working
oh i'm sorry i'm just saying either way
i was it was a coin flip it was going to
be abroad i was [ __ ]
chubbing up yeah but if it's a guy you
know no no harm no
i'm no foul yeah yeah no for sure that's
funny
um all right we got one we can run
through a couple of more um
andrew miller that have you have you or
a family member ever been thrown out of
a little league sporting event for
arguing a call with the ref for the ump
oh
see once again my parents didn't put me
in sports
and if they did they wouldn't have come
to the game really yeah
they were distant huh very distant i
never i think i did judo once
but i think i did it once and uh i got
the ghee
i said hello i met the kids i got kicked
on the balls and we never went back
so your parents didn't sign you up for a
little league or anything like that
nothing
did you express interest in it well i
liked [ __ ] around i like
playing and stuff but uh sports never
no religion no sports no hugs that was
their motto
sounds like a warm household yeah it was
yikes it was waspy
it was uh it was cold in there like the
cosby's over there
jeez yeah yeah well cosby at least you
know put me to bed
i give you a drink yeah so yeah i went
to little league games i went with
friends
i would go to church with my friends
because it was something
really yeah you know you'd wake up on a
sleepover on sunday the mom's like we're
going to church and i was like i'll go
what's church like we were you know big
atheists so were you jealous not jealous
but were you
in awe of other like things completely
in awe wow especially the suburbs see
that makes me feel
so bad well it was fine but it was just
a new world like i lived in the inner
city and so these kids are throwing
their bikes on the lawn the mom comes
out with orange slices
the dad's like working on the carburetor
or some [ __ ] or he's grilling i was like
this is bananas yeah you need to go to
church and come back have lunch
yeah we'd go to like water parks and
picnics and
yeah by i learned a lot just from going
out with friends like this is normal
that's what normal is did you did you
have the house where you would have your
friends over or were you at
purely kind of most of the time out at
other people's places see my friends
liked my house because we were free it
was completely independent
there was no supervision and it was a
big weird you know
haunted house mansion so we were running
up and down we skateboarded in the front
parlor
and you know we're going under the house
with flashlights and [ __ ]
yeah so it's fun uh we could drink and
stuff but
you know going to their house was fun
for me because let's say it's a summer
me and kevin come over
all the same age we're in the backyard
with goof around is your mom coming out
hey do you guys want this you want some
lunch you want something like that
are these guys staying for dinner do you
guys want to sleep over or anything like
that or no
well i mean she was nice they're nice
they're nice people but my mom was you
know
rubbing one out to john luke picard on
the next generation
and my dad's doing taxes he's got a
green visor on he's pulling the lever
so we were we'd camp in the backyard
we'd make food we have a little fire
going in the backyard
that's pretty cool
[Laughter]
so it went both ways you know like i
told my parents i'm doing i'm going to
try to go in the stand up i moved to new
york they were like all right
so there's perks to it too yeah no i got
you yeah there was always that one
family though that did it a little bit
better and of course you know
it was nice yeah my sister was hot
[ __ ] yeah that was cool
it was americana yeah i'll tell you what
my parents didn't do a great they did a
fantastic did your parents fight in
front of you
in front of me personally or my friends
but in front of you or just fight and in
general my parents never [ __ ] they were
too distant
so that i never had i see my friend's
parents like oh [ __ ] you
pam i'm yeah you're lucky i'm still here
whatever and i was like
i was blown away in front of other kids
never yeah we were oppressed irish
family but it was a sunday and shit's
popped off and the [ __ ] windows were
closed
right yeah it got it got hot yeah but my
dad was always big
on never embarrassing the family out in
public
like that's like that's real poor people
[ __ ] yeah yeah we don't have much
but we can not be we cannot be animals
like the person next to us right
right we can keep up appearances while
we're here so many family parties that
we would go to
with you know there'd be you know five
different families there'd be all kids
my age and everybody's just running
around like animals
we'd be told don't be [ __ ] running
around in here don't be running through
these people's houses
and then if you forgot about that he'd
be sitting there with a [ __ ] you know
with a beer in his hand
you run by the kitchen table and he'd
[ __ ] grab you
[ __ ] tell you we're running in the
house it was it was all very
very quiet yeah very quiet argument shut
up don't say anything
he was even worse than my pop but my my
cousin was running through the house one
time and like he ran around the corner
my uncle was standing and he grabbed him
he's like
you keep running this house i'm going to
beat you till you bleed
i remember i just remember i put down my
shirley temple and called a camp
thanks for having me i'll be back at the
house [ __ ] that
i just love the idea hello united
i got a real live one here
you guys ever run away i i like two
minutes
i tried until i got hungry yeah i tried
and uh my dad being the [ __ ] you know
ball buster
[ __ ] i was like oh that's it i'm
[ __ ] out of here and you do the thing
where you get your school bag you pack
up your [ __ ] yep
ninja turtle and i go outside i'm
[ __ ] leaving right i was like seven
or something yeah and he goes
i don't know where the [ __ ] i was going
i don't want to be there i'll tell you
that much and i'm like i'm leaving and
he uh
he goes all right well here you're going
to need a couple of bucks for a cat
pulled out like a 20. here and he goes
i'll get you the phone button get the
phone
like really and i'm like i'll leave
really he's like yeah my mom's like stop
it dan like
that's awesome yeah i did the same
packed up a bag put like three cookies
in a sling shot
and then the cookies get
you get outside the gate you see like
black kids popping wheelies you're like
all right i'll be back
that's awesome my brother did that one
time and it was one it was like one of
those special moments because it was
like a lot of tension they were fight
they were
shooting my mom was yelling at my
brother and like we were fighting and
stuff like that
and i remember me and my mom just
laughing at my brother's face so hard
it was something about him in a little
league game the next day and like my mom
bluffing that he wasn't gonna be able to
go
because he was being bad and my brother
taking his like little league shirt and
folding it up and putting it in his
little league hat
and then putting it on his head yeah and
then getting on his bike and he's like
i'm leaving and me and my mom
just like [ __ ] the two old guys in
the muppets just falling over
laughing at him knowing he wasn't
[ __ ] going anywhere so you're older
older brother
i'm i'm younger my brother's older two
ways older oh okay wow
yeah and you only brother only brother
yes me and my brother
good times i got i was the youngest of
three and then my parents got divorced
my dad had two like
significantly younger kids oh okay so
you weren't really attached
i like kids not so much as we got sure
that we grew apart but
there's one that i'm 10 years older than
and one that i'm 16. oh yeah that's
another world yeah
what was you and your brother he's older
we're all youngest are you close
to him not real he's a tough nut to
crack he's very serious he's
he's almost like spectrum-y kind of i
think you know he's a
good guy and he's got two great kids and
a nice wife
and he's doing fine but it's uh we're so
we're like different different yeah it's
crazy
we're all we're all the youngest that's
something to be said for that that's
that's a comedy that's a comic thing
yeah
looking for attention approval yeah had
it a little easier
exactly yeah in the words of dave
chappelle we're the ice breaker yeah
we come in and say something stupid we
follow everybody's always like oh well
you're with the babies yeah like
everybody yeah you go to the baby nobody
cares about the
older one no no no no he's got boogers
in his nose did you guys have to perform
for your family when you were younger
yeah i i chose to i don't think they
liked it
okay because that was always the thing i
wasn't a fan
any any holiday any get together with my
immediate family at some point
i was clicking in and out at some point
there was going to be a show
yeah my cousin uh tracy was going to do
michael jackson
oh wow i was going to lick your [ __ ]
come on we're having fun i was going to
open up for
with [ __ ] couple of minutes do a
crazy eddie impersonation do a robin
leech impersonation we just wanted to
really
encourage that and like everybody in the
family were like performers
uh-huh i feel like you know that's where
it came from and it's like when you
watch the
eddie murphy's uh yes delirious yeah raw
and he's talking
about that yeah that's right exactly
again there was nothing good on
you couldn't just put on netflix so you
had to get drunk and make the kids do
[ __ ] [ __ ]
like uh my family is huge i have like
40 cousins or something now they all
have kids because i was like the
youngest one of them so they all have
like kids anywhere from like
20 to you know newborns and what they
all do is they still do the same thing
but it's all for tick tock now
like they all [ __ ] boy they're all like
yeah we're going to do the dance and
everybody watch us through the dance but
we're also going to film the dance and
and release the dance i'm sorry i feel
like it was better back then
i got it was softer we were we were
going i was i needed
we were going for laughs yeah and it was
it was a [ __ ] time
and i got booked at thanksgiving yeah it
was like an 80s comedy club it was like
filled with smoke they were
drunk you got to get in there you got to
get them you want to [ __ ] tell them
get the [ __ ] off quick now it's like you
know they're like
they're like half singing you're like
come on what is this [ __ ] i know
put some [ __ ] effort into it it's
different being in the room you know you
got to bring it but also
these kids probably perform for their
families like we did
so i just feel like we're moving further
and further apart
yeah as a species sure it's weird
yeah it is weird but i mean maybe that's
just the the natural aggression yeah
my grandfather was like looking at me
like this like
oh like i was ice skated too so they're
like this [ __ ] idiots out there on
the skateboard like
yeah i had a job when i was 12. you know
right good point good point
same here my grandfather [ __ ] he was
a korean vet he had he was a fighter
pilot he hated me
yeah oh yeah dude my my grandfather was
a philly cop for like [ __ ]
you know 50 years and still i still see
him to this day and he's sober now he's
like a bad he was a
you know alcoholic for a long time yeah
so he's been sober for like 40 years or
something
and every time i see him he goes how
much is a train ticking up to new york
he wants to know that and how much for a
beer do they charge you honey i play
along i'm like thirty two dollars
oh thirty two bucks thank you yeah every
it'll ask me five times a night every
day that's great world war ii
vietnam those guys are all tough those
korean war guys
are [ __ ] a different breed his name
is cleveland
so this guy is like cleveland this guy
cleveland williams and he has
what a name sounds like a black guy he
uh like he told me like back when he met
my grandmother
he had to have a chaperone her mom
had to come and like he's like you don't
know what it was like it was so much
work and all this i was like that is
insane that you had to wear a suit on
the date you know all that [ __ ]
absolutely it just feels like every inch
of discomfort we have
we like try to get rid of it and i think
that's gonna hurt us
at some point they relished it or they
had so much discomfort yeah and i think
they were happier
yeah you know we were like you always
hear what they were more distracted
maybe that's
they were like i got we have to
everything was harder and more time
consuming so yeah like
i just this is well this is life i don't
have time to worry about
who likes me and doesn't like right i
gotta perform on thanksgiving or
whatever they're just going yeah this is
[ __ ] life
i guess so yeah that was the good thing
about that generation is they if you
ever went to your grandfather or
something and was like oh this kid
doesn't like me they
gives a [ __ ] they didn't my dad
they didn't give a [ __ ] who thought what
about who i know i know and i'm like i
didn't get enough retweets
this post is getting nothing that's fun
all right let's do uh one more then we
can wrap it up we're coming up on an
hour here
uh this is uh i'm trying to think of a
good one to uh
to end it on here um
this is a pretty good one this is from
kevin i am morbidly obese but i got a
cue
stevens another [ __ ] history i mean
uh have you ever used a
tip calculator or a tip card
oh wow how do you well i guess my
question is how do you calculate the tip
when you go out
what do you do check comes how do you do
it well
i mean if they don't say it on a thing
yeah that's not on the bottom of the
thing which is a new thing
i'll break my phone out and i'll figure
out what 20 is and then i'll do
usually do more than that i heard you
double the tax that's what i always do
oh that's probably that's cheap people
[ __ ]
what's tax though in new york tax is
probably 10 percent it's 10 so i just
doubled yeah what am i giuliani i don't
know
what's going on better be a [ __ ] 20
when i come back to get that thing i'll
tell you that
yeah i give 20 i mean that's about my
default yeah i thought double in the tip
but
i think in new york that works because
it's like nine or ten percent is the tax
yeah okay
that should work out but i have no
problem breaking up the phone and you
know i just do i do two times the
ten number if it's 40 bucks two times
four is it
okay that's pretty good oh there you go
so it's two bucks for every ten
i notice a lot some people are old
school like uh i would run in the tables
where
they wouldn't leave anything they didn't
want to leave the tip on the card i want
to give you
uh they don't know what are you doing
every
that's a brand new mic we just i don't
know what to tell you they don't they
don't know who's just bought that
yesterday
who's going to get the money make sure
you get it oh that's hilarious yeah so
they leave it in case don't pool
it yeah yeah this goes for you yeah
which i when i was working tipped i
didn't mind putting a little in the old
uh
backpack of course of course not making
it into the pool yeah
trust these [ __ ] scumbags i'm working
with by the way you know the game of
pool
is called pool because you used to pool
the money it's called pocket billiards
ah but it started like it was like
gambling oh let's play pool
yeah let's pull the money who came up
with that aha
that is a trashy piece of knowledge
yeah they're holding a weapon i went on
to want of like the upper east side like
103rd and [ __ ] second or something
i was like yeah we're playing pool i
went in there i [ __ ] one loop in one
loop out
that was almost dicey that was also the
height of luxury as a kid like it's got
a [ __ ] pool table
oh about that dude that was insane
killer and if it was a red one it's over
oh
that was big and a red pool table those
parents were [ __ ]
right they were into some weird yeah
the real money was the one that would
collect at the one not
stop in the pockets the one that had the
system
and you would get them at the end of the
pool team right that was real my buddy
had one of those and it didn't have the
ch you know
a cigarette machine in the corner
how about the art guy with the arcade
game at his house oh the pinball machine
dude the epitome the epitome of my buddy
his dad
making new money like they were [ __ ]
trash yeah they made a [ __ ] ton of money
and he got a urinal installed in the
edition on their what
they had a urinal dude i've never heard
of that and it was like he's like wait
till you see this we're gonna have a
urinal we're like yeah yeah yeah
ribbon on that thing
had the big scissors the mayor was there
he gave a little speech
holy [ __ ] gang what a [ __ ] episode
mark norman thank you much for sitting
there with us thank you so much
we appreciate it of course shout out to
our producer
extraordinaire the amazing toby mcmullen
everybody uh we will be back
next week for another exciting episode
of are you garbage you got anything for
them
listen to tuesdays with stories with me
and joe list uh it's on anywhere you can
get podcasts and out to lunch
on uh youtube fantastic about four mil
and counting [ __ ] netflix [ __ ] these
queefs these networks
can suck my ass youtube's the future
and uh yeah marknorm.com for merch and
anal and jizz
yeah guys go check out his stuff he's
one of the funniest guys in the country
hardest one of the one probably the
hardest working comic in new york
absolutely [ __ ] killer go check out
his special it's free on youtube go
check it out
as always just please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube those numbers are
[ __ ] climbing through the roof we
appreciate that and then obviously the
patreon to help us [ __ ] pay the bills
we went on our own we're rolling the
[ __ ] dice let's [ __ ] do it
support the [ __ ] guys you know what i
mean yes sir and the store is open pod
merch
with all of our teas we got tease
podcastmarch.com check it out please
uh get yourself something for the
holiday season buy it for a friend buy
it for a loved one yeah
we love you guys and we will see you
next week